well you've worked in film finance for
what 10 years yeah why crowdfunding 2
reasons with web shows like the star
mine record its last times acceleration
it is and this is pay attention guys it
is highly highly highly unlikely that
that webseries will ever make you money
directly it is not a revenue generating
model yes the guild has sponsors the
guild also has stars from Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and star trek and a whole
community that people want to see and
that's what gets companies like
Microsoft involved do not depend on your
web series as a revenue generating model
so don't look for investors don't do it
it doesn't make any sense you know and I
believe I love the guilt and I am in awe
of what you have accomplished Felicia
Day and honestly you're an inspiration I
would never have made the star mine
record if it wasn't for shows like yours
and I'm very proud of what I did so
thank you
but the sermon record has not made us
one red cent however it is something we
can give to the audience that's cool
and it gets people involved and it gives
people a reason to stick around and hang
out and then we can make a movie because
there's all these people because the
lights are up and the curtains open and
there they are you know and that's what
a web series is good for it so don't be
looking for money from your web series
because you're very unlikely to find it
and it's just you're skating uphill try
and find it what another way to finance
it and the other side of it is that I am
for all my flannel planets experience
not a wealthy man my my I've been
successful in so far as I have financed
feature films and that is taught me a
lot but for example the development
money that we pulled together for a
quantum theory has been spent on putting
the contracts together getting our
budget in place paying our line producer
who is amazing and
name is aimy flirty and I love you any
flirty and and paying people that we
need to get the infrastructure on board
so that we can start bringing in
investors and showing them this
community that we have in showing them
showing them the open theater you know
it's also giving me the ability to
secure relationships on an exhibition
level we have a theatrical plan for
quantum theory that's already in place
so that's good but what we do not have
is development money so reaching out
asking for that help receiving that help
has helped us put us in a position where
we can turn around and start talking to
investors so that we can make the movie
so that we can make the money so that we
can have development money and a payroll
and you know all that all the things
that come with a successful running busy
production company which is ultimately
what we are building
you